BE TRACKING YOUR EVERY MOVE.
WE HAVE SOME MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS ON THAT
TONIGHT.
BUT, FIRST, HOUSE MAJORITY
LEADER NANCY PELOSI
DELIVERED THE LONGEST SPEECH
IN HOUSE HISTORY TODAY.
APPARENTLY SHE WENT ON FOR
MORE THAN 8 HOURS IN AN
EFFORT TO PRESSURE CONGRESS
TO GIVE AMNESTY TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> SO NOW WE HAVE THE FIRST
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT IN
MODERN TIME, THE FIRST
PRESIDENT, REALLY WHO IS
ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
>> TO MINUTESTER TO THE
NEEDS OF GOD’S CREATION IS
AN ABILITY OF WORSHIP.
TO IGNORE THOSE NEEDS IS TO
DISHONOR THE GOD WHO MADE
US.
>> WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR
SOMETHING OFF THE WALL --
YEAH MAYBE IT SOFT WALL.
>> THE VOTE WILL YIELD SOON
UNTIL I YIELD BACK.
I HAVE NITTANY LION TENSION
OF YIELDING BACK,
MR. SPEAKER.
>> NEWCOMERS WITH ALL OF
THAT HOPE AND ASPIRATION
THEY MAKE AMERICA MORE
AMERICAN.
>> Tucker: WENT ON FOR MANY
HOURS LIKE THIS.
SHE SAID MANY THINGS.
ONE THING SHE SAID WAS
STRIKING.
LISTEN HOW SHE DESCRIBES HOW
HER GRANDSON BADLY WISHES HE
WERE OF A DIFFERENT RACE.
WATCH.
>> I’M REMINDED OF MY OWN
GRANDSON.
HE HAD A VERY CLOSE FRIEND
WHOSE NAME IS ANTONIO, IS HE
FROM GUATEMALA.
AND HE HAS BEAUTIFUL, TAN
SKIN, BEAUTIFUL BROWN EYES.
AND THE REST.
AND THIS WAS SUCH A PROUD
DAY FOR ME BECAUSE WHEN MY
GRANDSON BLEW OUT THE
CANDLES ON HIS CAKE, THEY
SAID DID YOU MAKE A WISH?
AND HE SAID YES, I MADE A
WISH.
>> I SAID WHAT IS YOUR WISH?
HE SAID I WISH I HAD BROWN
SKIN AND BROWN EYES LIKE
ANTONIO.
SO BEAUTIFUL.
THE BEAUTY IS IN THE MIX.
>> Tucker: WAS IT HEALTHY TO
HATE YOURSELF FOR THE WAY
THAT GOD MADE YOU?
NANCY PELOSI THINKS IT IS.
THEY’RE DELIGHT SAYS
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
CERTAIN RACES ARE GOOD.
OTHERS ARE BAD.
SO BAD THAT IT’S CONSIDERED
BEAUTIFUL TO HATE YOUR OWN
INNATE APPEARANCE AND WANT
IT CHANGED.
AND THAT PELOSI IS SAYING
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS SHE
SUPPORTS MASS IMMIGRATION SO
AMERICA WILL LOOK DIFFERENT
AND IN HER VIEW BETTER THAN
IT DOES NOW.
NOW, WHATEVER YOU THINK OF
THAT IDEA, IT IS A GENUINELY
RADICAL SENTIMENT.
NOBODY HAS SAID ANYTHING
LIKE THAT ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY USED TO.
BUT THEY DON’T ANYMORE.
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
ELEVATING ONE RACE OVER
ANOTHER IS THE DEFINITION OF
DIG GOT TRI.
PELOSI MAY NOT BE SHARP
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT SHE
JUST SAY.
SHE MAY NOT KNOW WHAT SHE IS
SAYING.
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE EVERYONE
DOESN’T HATE EVERYONE ELSE
FOR THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN,
YOU OUGHT NOT SAY THINGS
LIKE THAT.
DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO STOP
TALKING LIKE THIS IN PUBLIC.
THE WHITE HOUSE MEANWHILE
CHIEF OF STAFF SAYING
HUNDREDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS DIDN’T SIGN UP
FOR DACA IN PART BECAUSE
SOME OF THEM MAY HAVE BEEN
TOO LAZY, WATCH.
>> THERE ARE 690,000
OFFICIAL DACA REGISTRANTS.
AND THE PRESIDENT SENT OVER
WHAT AMOUNTS TO BE 2 AND A
HALF TIMES THAT NUMBER TO
1.8 MILLION.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN 690
AND 1.8 MILLION WERE THE
PEOPLE THAT SOME WOULD SAY
WERE TOO AFRAID TO SIGN UP,
OTHERS WERE WOO SAY WERE TOO
LAZY TO GET OFF THEIR -- BUT
THEY DIDN’T SIGN UP.
>> Tucker: THE LEFT IS
HOWLING OF COURSE AND
JUMPING UP AND DOWN LIKE THE
HYENAS THEY ARE.
DACA DID EXIST FOR FIVE
YEARS WITH CARVE OUT PEOPLE
BROUGHT HERE UNDER THE AGE
OF 18.
A LOT OF WAYS TO HELP PEOPLE
SIGN UP FOR IT PROGRAMS,
TRANSLATER EMPLOYERS.
AT LOVE THINGS TO HELP
IMMIGRANTS APPLY.
YET MORE THAN A MILLION
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY TO THE PROGRAM FAILED
TO DO SO.
WHY IS THAT?
EXACTLY?
WHAT DOES IT TELL US ABOUT
THEM?
ROBERTO HERNANDEZ IS AN
IMMIGRATION ACTIVIST.
HE JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> HEY, TUCKER.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> Tucker: I’M DOING GREAT.
I THINK IT’S A REALLY
INTERESTING QUESTION.
SO THE MAJORITY THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM, WHICH I THINK IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT IT EXISTED.
THEY DIDN’T SIGN UP FOR THE
PROGRAM.
NOW, MAYBE SOME WOULD SAY
THEY ARE LAZY.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S THE
EXPLANATION.
I THINK THEY JUST DIDN’T
CARE THINK DIDN’T CARE ABOUT
OUR LAW.
THEY DIDN’T CARE ABOUT THE
FOLLOWING THE RULES IN A
COUNTRY THAT’S NOT THEIRS.
SO HE THIS DIDN’T.
I THINK THAT’S WORSE THAN
LAZINESS, HONESTLY.
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER,.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
OH MY GOD, FIRST OF ALL, I
CAN’T BELIEVE JOHN KELLY THE
CHIEF OF STAFF OF THE WHITE
HOUSE OF THIS COUNTRY USING
THAT KIND OF LANGUAGE?
YOU KNOW, TO ME, IT’S LIKE
IT REMINDS ME OF THE BULLIES
IN 3RD GRADE.
AND IF YOU REALLY LOOK AT
GUY PEOPLE NOT APPLY?
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID, TUCKER.
LOOK AT ALL THE ICE RAIDS
THAT ARE GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: NO, THIS IS NOT
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS.
>> PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN
RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, OKAY.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
>> BEAUTIFUL BROWN SKIN AS
WE’RE.
>> Tucker: IT’S NOT ABOUT
THAT.
IT’S NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS.
THEY ARE NOT PICKING ON ANY
OTHER RACE.
THEY ARE PICKING ON ANY
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY OTHER.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SINGLE
HANDEDLY MAKING ME VERY
AGAINST MAKING ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE BECOME CITIZENS
BECAUSE YOU ARE MAKING IT A
RACIAL QUESTION IT’S A
QUESTION OF CITIZENSHIP.
THESE PEOPLE ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
OBAMA SAID LOOK I’M GOING TO
LET YOU STAY THUNDER
PROGRAM.
I’M GOING TO LET YOU SIGN UP
UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
NOT TRUMP, OBAMA, FIVE YEARS
AGO AND MOST OF THEM DIDN’T
SIGN UP.
NOW, TRUMP IS SAYING I’M
GIVING YOU CITIZENSHIP
ANYWAY.
I TOTALLY DISAGREE WITH
WHATEVER, THAT’S THE FACT.
BUT THE POINT IS THEY DIDN’T
SIGN UP.
WHAT WERE THEY AFRAID OF?
THE OBAMA PEOPLE ARE LIKE WE
ARE HELPING YOU, GIVE YOU A
TRANSLATOR.
YOU STILL WON’T DO IT?
WHY.
BECAUSE YOU DON’T CARE.
YOU DON’T CARE ABOUT BEING
LEGAL.
WHAT’S THE OTHER
EXPLANATION?
>> BUT, LET’S LOOK, OKAY,
BRING UP TRUMP.
NOW THAT YOU BRING UP TRUMP.
>> Tucker: IT WAS UNDER
OBAMA, MAN, TUNE IN.
>> HE CREATED A CRISIS FOR
DACA.
SIMPLE.
IT WASN’T A CRISIS UNTIL HE
MADE IT A CRISIS.
DISTRACTION FOR THIS COUNTRY
WHEN WE HAVE SOME OTHER
ISSUES.
>> Tucker: I COULDN’T AGREE
MORE.
>> CRISIS WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT SHOULDN’T BE
THE TOPIC OF THIS SUBJECT OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I COULDN’T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE.
WE FOUND COMMON GROUND.
>> USING IT AS BLACKMAIL
TODAY.
GIVE ME THE WALL.
>> Tucker: JUST ANSWER THIS
ONE QUESTION.
UNDER BARACK OBAMA, WHO
OFFERED THIS PROGRAM TO
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY HE
SAID LOOK, I WILL LET YOU
STAY, GIVE YOU LEGAL STATUS
AND HELP YOU SIGN UP FOR IT
THERE IS NOTHING I WON’T DO
TO HELP YOU SIGN UP FOR IT
MOST OF THEM SAID NOT
INTERESTING.
I’M TURNING DOWN THE
PROGRAMS AND TRANSLATER AND
THE SAFE SPACES YOU ARE
GIVING ME.
WHY?
DON’T TELL ME THEY ARE
AFRAID.
HE WAS ASKING THEM TO SIGN
UP AND HELPING THEM AND THEY
DIDN’T.
WHAT’S THE ANSWER?
WHY DIDN’T THEY DO THAT
UNDER BARACK OBAMA?
HONESTLY?
>> WELL, THAT WAS TEMPORARY.
AND BARACK OBAMA QUITE
CANDIDLY FAILED BY NOT
GETTING IMMIGRATION REFORM
DONE THE FIRST WE’RE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO ANSWER MY QUESTION, ARE
YOU?
>> NO, I AM.
I’M TRYING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
DIDN’T BARACK OBAMA PROMISE
THAT HE WAS GOING TO DIME
CONGRATULATION REFORM THE
FIRST YEAR THAT HE WAS IN
OFFICE?
>> Tucker: DOES THE
PRESIDENT MAKE THE LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY OR DOES THE
CONGRESS?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> IT’S CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, THERE YOU
GO.
GOOD.
SO CONGRESS DOES.
>> OBAMA ALSO HAS DEMOCRATIC
CONTROL HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI WAS THE HEAD OF
THAT HE ALSO HAD THE SENATE
THAT WAS DEMOCRATIC
CONTROLLED.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE NOT
ANSWERING MY QUESTION.
IT’S A REALLY INTERESTING
QUESTION.
I THINK IT TELLS YOU A LOT
ABOUT THIS POPULATION WE ARE
ABOUT TO GIVE CITIZENSHIP TO
VOTING IN OUR NEXT ELECTION
OR SOME SUBSEQUENT ELECTION.